hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from round four of
the 2018 Norway Championship it's again
between Levin Ariana and Shockley our
mummy DRF now we don't have any photos
from this round so instead I thought we
would play a little game I show you a
random photo of a chess player and you
have to guess who it is
now since this is the first time we're
doing this I'm really gonna make it
simple for you it's someone you all know
you've been seeing a lot of him lately
but it's a photo of him from when he was
a teenager so if you don't know who it
is I'm gonna really gonna take it as a
personal insult and I will really really
feel that I failed you so here it is I
really hope you all know who it is
let's see it so there he is and I really
hope you know at least 95% of you know
who this is
I will not even say who it is because I
am that positive that you all know it so
before we check out the game
it's a very interesting game it features
a line that we've already seen in my
previous video in a game between Cara
Kane and MVL only it takes takes a
different path but it's also interesting
that it also follows the game that was
played in 2006 between Veselin Topalov
and Peter Svidler but then at some point
my media of comes up with a totally
different preparation and it's very
interesting how Oregon had you know
deals with this preparation over the
board so let's see it
we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to
c3 and d5 same as in the previous game
the groom for defense C capture snipe
captures c4 Knight captures on c3 BC 3
and the Bishop to g7 so Bishop to c4 all
the moves are completely the same as in
the game between kurakin and mvl 92
castles castles Knight to c6 Bishop to
e3 and here it was in this position that
mvl went for b6 where Kirk and preceded
D captures on c5 here mama D ro goes for
Knight to a5 attacking the bishop on c4
Bishop to d3
now comes b6 and here rook the c1 it's
very interesting why not capture the
pawn here it seems like it's a free pawn
captures captures and Becca
so why not do it grabbing a nice bone
like this well black gets too much
activity and after Queen to c7 your your
Bishop is under attack if you move the
bishop the c3 point is attacked twice
from the Queen and the bishop and if you
play something like Bishop before if you
want to keep material then after a five
black will really again a lot of
activity and also will win the bush
repair after Knight to c4 so your Bishop
is attacked now you will black will
either grab or after captures captures
it's a very weak c3 pawn black will win
it eventually and black also has the
bishop pair so definitely enough
compensation for the pawn
so after b6 rook to c1 by our onion e5
and this is the idea it's been played
plenty of times even on another high
level the strongest game in this line
was probably Veselin Topalov versus
Peter Svidler in 2006 so we're gonna use
that game as a reference and this can
this game continues in the same path he
captures on c5 Bishop to e6 c4 now big
characters on c5 Bishop captures on c5
and this is where you know the game
takes new form in their game swittel
sweeter played rook to e8 simply the
bishop is attacking the rook so he moved
the rook and Veselin Topalov
one dead game but for this game mama drf
prepared Bishop to h6 so instead of
moving the attack rook he attacks the
rook and c1 himself
we have wrote the c3 not moving the rook
for example if if you if you go for
Bishop captures on a fade then Bishop
captures on c1 Knight captures King
captures and after after Queen to c2
look to c8 c5 and bloom to d4 black will
always win this extra pawn white has and
then the compensation will be real so
after this Bishop to h6
we have looked the c3 by our nm rook to
e8
also getting the rock out of harm's way
Queen to c2 preparing to protect that's
extra c4 pawn queen to c7 and Bishop to
a3 now
so the c4 point is currently attacked
three times and defended three times
rook 8b8
we have a ch3 rocky to d8 and bush
to see one now trying to exchange the
dark square bishop push up to f/8
mama Daryl doesn't allow this and Bishop
to g5 I very active square for the
Bishop rook to d7
we have c5 now you know test points must
be pushed and now h6 Bishop to e3 and
Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 now
offering a trade of bishops and here we
have Knight d4 and a little bloodbath in
the middle of the board Bishop captures
he captures on d4 we have Bishop
captures on e6 pawn captures rook Bishop
captures rook Queen captures Bishop and
Knight captures pawn as you can see
White is currently up two points and
it's not possible to immediately grab
the C pawn if you capture it immediately
then white gets too much activity after
Knight to d5 now your Bishop is attacked
on c5 Knight f6 is a threat for King the
Queen and the king and after Bishop to
e7 preventing both threats after you
exchange rooks white will infiltrate the
position well either on b8 or if black
stops this using b7 and we'll simply
have simply have too much activity there
for example even if let's say h5 queen
v8 is coming this comes with check if
you move the king then Queen e5 check
will win the bishop and if you move
let's say h7 then then white will have
an extremely active position so after
Knight is Knight to c3 first momager
goes for Queen to d4 now there's a
double attack and now it's okay to win
the pawn c6 again pushing the passed
pawn queen to c4 and rook to c1 so Aaron
will give up the the second extra pawn
but he will gain a lot of activity in
the process Queen captures and now
Knight to d5 Queen captures rook
captures exchanging Queens rook to b1
check King h2 and now if you look at
this position white is still up upon
black has no compensation for the pond
and this is the idea behind the title of
the video look at this beautiful light
square and this Knight occupying it it's
very nice because look at all the
squares this Knight is controlling so
you know it's a beautiful piece and
especially since it's on a white square
and black
the dark square bishop black has no
means of ever getting rid of this night
from d5 the rook cannot move it Bishop
cannot move it and of course the King
cannot move it
so if white wants white can keep it
there for the rest of the game so okay
King to g7 we have f4 grabbing more
space we have rook to e1 and now II five
g5 g 3 we have rook to d1 933 attacking
the rook rook d3 and knife to g4 now
Bishop to d7 and now f5 with the threat
of f6 winning winning the Bishop Bishop
to d8 we have f6 now in discount with
check King h7 and now you are 11 Aragon
in this position pause the video here
and try to find the best move for white
that will that will eventually win you
the game as usual I will give it a
couple of seconds for you to decide so
okay for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations you are an
excellent pawn pusher and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
here our onion played a 6 and a 6 you
know it's a very it's a very nice move
you cannot prevent it with something
like rook to e3 the Knight is guarding
that Square of course you cannot allow a
7 then there's really no no no going
back and after F captures what was
played in the game you do not want to be
hasty with f7 then King will simply
block and even if you capture on h6 ok
it's a nice idea but should be 7 and
black black is defending so simply after
F captures only six rook F 2 you put a
rock behind a passed pawn and now there
really is no good way of preventing this
pawn bishop to c7 mama D are always
looking for some contra play as he
attacks the g3 pawn but our onion
doesn't care
f7 Bishop captures discount with check
King g2 and now there is no time to grab
the rook of course a bishop has to go
back and he it has to sacrifice itself
for the further newly arrived Queen so
Queen to f8 Bishop captures rook
captures and now rook comes to a three
attacks the pawn and rook to f2 so white
is up a knight but black has two points
as compensation for the night it's of
course a better position for white but
in practical terms it's never an easy
tasks especially against a 2,800 player
sole king g6 rookie - King h5
we have Knight f6 check King moves
attacks tonight and Knight moves back we
have E 5 rook to c2 King comes to f5 and
Knight G 3 check King e6 and rock to
rock back to f2 we have came to d5
Knight to f5 rook to a6 has to protect
the h6 pawn and now King to f3 so Aragon
managed to force this rook to go back so
now the King can activate it himself
rook to a3 check King goes to g4 and now
of course King wants to come to h5 and
start grabbing those spots so h5 the
King will grab it and then our madero
can grab the h3 pawn
so King captures rook captures with
check and Kim captures and this is my
maderos idea he knows there is very
little chance he will save this game but
he he will at least try to win to win
White's last pawn and even if he has to
give up both of his pawn pawns into me
in the meantime then he he can maybe
hold the draw in a king and rook against
the king and rook and Knight endgame so
efore into g4 attacking the rook rook
back to a3 rocky to king g5 night to g3
with a double attack on the rook rook a
for defending and king to h3 king f4 and
we have King to g2 g3 now pushing that
point even further we have worked a bit
too and now rook to a3 and even though
white is the one that has the extra
piece it seems like black is the one
pushing white back and that that is the
power of the of the past pawn nice to
eat you check king moves king f1 King D
3 King to e1 and rook to a6
we have into d1 rook to h6 rook to b3
check King moves and it was in this
position and move 70 iron played rook to
be four check and sha clear mama Dara
finally decided to turn in the towel and
he resigned the game there is well he
could you know give some more resistance
but after something like King to f3
rocket for check is coming king g2 and
after King si - you know it's he doesn't
really have a lot to do this rook is
cutting off the king completely the king
is you know allowed to only use the G
and the H file and the rook can do can
do very little after rook a six a four
is coming now the rook is cutting off
the king and also guarding the a four
pawn and the white king will either win
the e3 pawn or if black prevents this
will go for the a seven point
immediately but black is completely out
of the game now so yeah after rook to be
for Mama D ro resign in the game and a
very nice victory for xi Aragon who goes
back to 50% after losing that game to
Magnus Carlsen so it's a it's a very
nice game and like I said I will not be
showing you the standings we will only
show the standings after a couple of
games from round five as Dingley rain
has left the tournament and it would
make a little a little sense to show the
standings now as you know it you know it
would be a huge handicap for Caruana so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it and we'll see we'll see what
round 5 brings us we have a we have a
very important match up Magnus Carlsen
is playing against - wanna turn on and
his old rival so you know that yeah that
can always only go well so once again
here he is I really do hope you all know
know who it is and yeah as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
probably with another game from the
Norway Championship only from round five
so thank you all and I'll see you soon